hi this is Tim Ferriss and welcome back
to masterpiece theater kidding we are
gonna talk about books and specifically
I'm going to cover a few books that I
found very enjoyable in the last few
years and also I'm going to talk about
note-taking how I digest books how I
synthesize different pieces of books so
that it's not just in one eye and out
the other so to speak because consuming
a ton of information especially if it's
just in case information instead of just
in time information is largely a waste
of time its recreation but it's not
retention okay so I'm gonna talk about
how I go through books and I'm gonna use
a few fun examples first one I'll talk
about is travels with Charlie in search
of America John Steinbeck this is an
incredible book beautifully written
simply written and hilarious I really
did not expect this to be as funny as it
was it was recommended to me by my mom
my mom and my brother are both book
snobs so if they recommend anything it's
clear to high hurdle and you can see
here on the inside I make indices I make
an index in each book and I do it in
typically one of two ways or I'll
combine them here you will notice that I
have written down page numbers with
brief descriptions of what I found
interesting so I have in quotation marks
the ancient shutter I liked that
phrasing so in many books I'll put pH
next to it and then I'll write that down
which indicates the second way I can do
an index so this is page numbers
description the other way I might do
this in a book that's beautifully
written is I will put say pH up
somewhere
that means phrasing and then underneath
that I'll write down all of the various
phrases that I found interesting the
wordsmithing that I found beautiful or
just the page numbers and then they will
be underlined on those respective pages
alright so we have just to give you a
sample okay we have the ancient shutter
that's a phrase guns and fishing as
pretext I'm guessing for conversation
living fiercely there are many many many
quotes in here
you will also notice there are a few
that are starred there two here that are
starred and one is circled and within
book notes I'll very often do that for
potential next actions or things that I
could test so if we take a look at 79
it says different Church / denomination
every Sunday and I will flip to page 79
and it is a discussion of John's
experience going to many different
churches and there's a lot of great
great great great writing in here but
I'll just jump to the part that caught
my perspective all right but this
Vermont God cared enough about me to go
to a lot of trouble kicking the hell out
of me he put my sins in a new
perspective whereas they had been small
and mean and nasty and best forgotten
this Minister gave them some size and
bloom and dignity
I hadn't been thinking very well of
myself for some years but if my sins had
this dimension there was some pride left
I wasn't a naughty child but a
first-rate sinner and I was going to
catch it and it goes on and on and then
later on the page it says all across the
country I went to a church on Sundays a
different denomination every week and I
thought this was worth pondering as an
experiment as a way to stretch my
thinking broaden perspectives and become
exposed to different subcultures and
belief systems in the United States that
is 79 now if we come back see you here
that's 79 then we jump to 179
self-contempt and then an arrow that has
fine target you'll notice this goes on
and on I've got notes on Texas coffee
with egg whites and shells question mark
and I was interested in maybe trying
that but let's jump to the self-contempt
with the arrow to find target and this
is a discussion of his trip to a vet
with his dog Charlie that's why the book
is called travels with Charlie it's a
road trip around the United States with
his dog in the passenger seat or in the
back of the RV and Charlie has gotten
sick so he takes his dog to the vet and
the vet for lack of a better descriptor
is just dick the guy is not friendly and
this is what John says as he's leaving
or what he writes I should say I took
the little pills and paid my bill and
got out of there it and this is the part
I underlined I'll show you you can see
how it's all underlined and this is
start all right it wasn't that this
veterinary meaning veterinarian it
wasn't that this veterinary didn't like
animals I think he didn't like himself
and when that is though the subject
usually must find an area for dislike
outside himself else he would have to
admit his self contempt I thought that
was very interesting and I believe
Krista Tippett does a podcast on being
very very smart woman has been quoted as
saying something like anger is fear
shown in public something along those
lines so this talks about self-contempt
manifesting as anger or contempt towards
an outside object otherwise you have to
admit your own self contempt on some
level which is very hard to digest so
that is one book a very funny beautiful
poignant meaningful book for me and
we'll take a look at a few other genres
so the next book is straight how to this
is a how-to book excellent how to book
this is writing down the bones freeing
the writer with ends was recommended to
me many many times by a number of
professional writers who are excellent
writers and good friends of mine by
natalie goldberg foreword by Julia
Cameron some of you may recognize that
name she wrote a classic called the
artists way and popularized the practice
of mourning pages this is one of those
books that was recommended recommended
recommended and eventually I saw the
books and I was like you know now is the
time this is a sign and I bought the
book and I have many notes inside and
you will notice some similarities to the
previous index that I've shown and
travels with Charlie so a page number of
fundamental time to exercise and I
create this index without the circles
and stars then a day later a week later
I will go through
and I will star then I'll go through a
week later and circle and in that way I
am able to identify which chapters which
techniques I have found most useful
repeatedly because upon first reading
first pass I might find something
incredibly striking that later proves to
not be terribly useful but in this case
time to exercise fundamental this simply
means blocking out almost like the
Pomodoro Technique say 20 minutes for
writing that's it start to finish you
have to keep the pen or keyboard moving
and 39 this was when I returned to
multiple times allow yourself to be
awkward so giving yourself permission to
as I might put otherwise say write two
crappy pages per day as a quota that's
not her language but something I think
about definition of freedom this was
starred encircled so we're gonna jump to
that for a second I haven't looked at
this in a while let's see why I found
that interesting alright here we go
and yes you can see the various
highlights original detail these
chapters are very short so the book is
also written to be consumed very easily
which I like and I found the form out of
the book itself noteworthy and a lesson
in writing so here we have the piece I
found interesting there's freedom and
being a writer and writing it is
fulfilling your function I used to think
freedom meant doing whatever you want
and then I would say in parentheses but
instead it means knowing who you are
what you were supposed to be doing on
this earth and then simply doing it but
that there's a lot more to it but the
part I found interesting about this was
I used to think freedom was doing
whatever you want that is common
definition it's a definition that I get
pulled into much like a riptide because
it is conventional it's a definition
I've used often myself but there's a lot
of freedom and constraints and there is
a lot of freedom and focus but it takes
a reframing of that word so I found that
very interesting and helpful rather in
this book and then you can see here
abstract country or original detail so
forth and so on
so that's writing down the bones this is
straight how to but the index is
nonetheless very similar alright I heard
God laughing poems of hope and joy
renderings of huh Fez by daniel the
dense key a fez is a famed persian poet
mystic and sufi and these renditions or
renderings of huh Fez can be thought of
on some level as translations but
translations are always very contested
and you will see that same exact type of
index that I've used before and in this
case I'm simply highlighting poems awake
a while a ballroom view of love I know
the way you can get so allow me to read
you a poem which I never do but I'll do
it right now since we're all friends
here all right let's try a barroom view
of love how fast I should say I love for
a million different reasons one of which
is humor he's hilarious really really
hilarious and just to to put this in
perspective how Fez whose given name was
Shaun's would Dean Muhammad I'm sure I'm
not pronouncing that right but circa 13
22 1389 is the most beloved poet of
Persians 1300s keep that in mind
a barroom view of love here we go I
would not want all my words to parade
around this world in pretty costumes so
I will tell you something of the barroom
view of love love is grabbing hold of
the great lion's mane and wrestling and
rolling deep into existence while the
beloved that's God while the beloved
gets rough and begins to maul you alive
true love my dear is putting an ironclad
grip upon the source Wolin balls of a
divine rogue elephant and not having the
good fortune to die so you may be
thinking to yourself that Ferris has
gone nuts he's gone cuckoo bananas but I
find that a lot of meaning
and many interesting oh that's a lazy
adjective thought-provoking questions
can be embedded densely into poetry
so how Fez is one of my favorites here
you have it I would recommend starting
with the gift as a compilation but if
you like what you heard then you may
enjoy I heard God laughing next up we're
gonna jump to a different format Kindle
I use Kindle whenever possible because
it allows me to export my highlights so
I will highlight in this device then I
will go see my highlights and there are
different options for software you can
use for this but the most native would
be Amazon notebook so you can find your
Kindle highlights then when you log in
through your account on Amazon notebook
and you can then copy and paste those or
import them in two different programs I
often will web clip that into Evernote
where I can then go through my
highlights much like the multiple passes
and the print books and add three
asterisks so three stars so to speak
next two things that I find interesting
in my highlights interesting I'm loving
that adjective today on multiple passes
and then I can just use ctrl F and
search for those asterisks three
asterisks to find the highlights of the
highlights of the highlights and in this
way I can review books after I've done a
few passes of the highlights I can
review what are most salient in terms of
points and lessons and actions in a few
minutes
might be a five to ten minute review of
a book that took me five to ten hours to
read alright so I'll show you a book
here which is already free and this is
in Chapter three but this is what it
looks like and you can adjust the
brightness of the screen very easily I
won't bore us by going through a tech
tutorial of the Kindle but here is the
paragraph that I found most gripping in
this particular part of the chapter and
it actually ties into a bunch in
the previous books that I've spoken
about in terms of perception stories
narratives we tell ourselves and so on
here we go and this is in the context of
psychotherapy Western developmental
psychotherapy combined with Buddhist
fruitional view relating to whatever is
and that might sound very strange but
this book already free was recommended
to me highly by Marcelo Marcela with AH
Laura who is a therapist and also runs
much of the training if not all the
training for maps the multidisciplinary
--ss association of psychedelic studies
who is conducting phase 3 trials on
mdma-assisted psychotherapy for PTSD
that's how I got to this book another
helpful reframe is to present all of our
out-of-date survival strategies as an
expression of our health our best
efforts to take care of ourselves
another is to offer the view that
whatever happens to us when young if you
want to strengthen our sense of being an
adult it's important to practice an
attitude of complete responsibility for
working with our experience regardless
of how it might have been shaped by our
history and it talks quite a lot about
practicing taking inventory of your
sensations and feelings much like a Komi
therapy when certain stories come up oh
my boss always does this
oh this that and the other victim
narrative that might pop up as an
example so this is a book and I have
greatly enjoyed and a format that I
greatly prefer when possible because I
have many cases taking copious notes in
print books and then lost the print book
that is a sad day ladies and gentlemen
makes me very very sad alright the last
book that I'm going to talk about is
this one here and it is a hilarious book
it is a useful book full of lessons
alright in pursuit of the common good 25
years of improving the world one bottle
of salad dressing at a time Paul Newman
and AE I'm guessing Hotchner but
those one of those Ellis Island
situations I don't know how to pronounce
that in Americanized English nonetheless
the back I'll just do give a quick read
here shameless exploitation has never
been more fun or done more good for more
people than when done by newman's own
the first green food company to use all
natural ingredients and still the most
successful alright if we jump into this
this is a effectively a business memoir
but full of great lessons and how-to
advice so if you look here you can see I
have tons and tons of notes and this is
a page driven index and it goes on and
on it goes beyond the two pages but if
we look at this page there are
negotiating notes importance of terms
page 48 you can see 53 plus PR stunts
launch make it a joke there's a lot of
humor and a lot of using PR to drive a
suppose social cause entrepreneurship
which I found fascinating they did very
very little paid advertising or
marketing but a lot of PR and a lot of
telling good stories the vast majority
of which were parodies or satire all
right so we have revenue numbers I
wanted to track their revenue numbers as
it corresponded to different types of
initiatives to try to correlate in my
mind at least what had potential causal
effects alright using puns long names
ridiculous claims right one of their
claims on one of the products was
restores virginity that's what's known
as puffery I think that would be
considered puffer legally speaking if
you buy a shampoo that says volumizing
hair volumizing that is no scientific
meaning and so it is not a structure or
function claim that the FDA would have
problems with it's just made-up quackery
basically
and there's term for that pretty sure
they're words puffery so when you make a
ridiculous claim like restores virginity
it is so beyond the realm of
believability that it becomes something
you can use that is my understanding not
a lawyer so consult your legal counsel
before doing anything like that
and I highlighted a few things fake /
stunts news release well it's their
crafting of news releases was just
brilliant 1:13 I started three times so
charity competitions three annual events
fake interviews incredible writing
hahaha and then in the bottom right here
there is something worth noting so very
often when I'm taking notes I'll have
these boxes in the bottom right hand
page and those are prospective next
steps next actions so it doesn't get
lost in all of the various notes
especially when I'm taking tons of notes
as I would on a book like how to change
your mind by Michael Pollan pages and
pages of notes so to create some
semblance of order for next actions
because I'm always looking for next
action it's great you read a book so
what how is it going to affect your
behavior or your beliefs your actions
and it took in a audiobooks list of
unlikely suspects in support of
psychedelic scientific research question
mark to de-risk CD media top teams at
bottom that's right all these ideas
based on the charity competition and
three annual events this is one thirteen
plus to copy and paste some of these
best practices into the cultivation of
scientific funding for psychedelic
related research which I was later able
to do so this and other books even
though seemingly unrelated helped me to
fundraise and raise half of so let's
just call it eight million nine eight
eight million or so dollars out of 17
for the first dedicated psychedelic and
consciousness Research Center at Johns
Hopkins which was a very big deal and
was featured on the cover of The New
York Times and the cover of the science
section
and it's because I am taking notes and
planning at least plausible next actions
and putting these things together and I
liberally will borrow from nonfiction to
think about imaginary worlds and fantasy
and fiction
I will also borrow liberally from
fiction saydoun and try to copy and
paste lessons learn about leadership as
an example into so-called real life and
the non-fiction realm so I love reading
but more than just reading I love
reading with real behavioral change
afterwards with real impact and I
certainly read things just for fun the
UH Fez I greatly enjoy but there is
value even if it's not obvious at the
outset so those are a few of the
approaches that I use they're not
necessarily the best but they work for
me for not just reading but taking
structured notes to better structure
thinking to make better decisions and to
have a greater impact on yourself on
those you care about and on the world in
general
you